we'll start the show in just a second
but first i want to tell you about
today's
sponsors nebia is a revolutionary shower
head that saves you money by using 45
percent less water but with a stream of
water that's way more powerful
than what you get with other shower
heads to get 15 percent off
go to nebia.com pacman and use the code
pacman
hydrant is the delicious fruit drink
powder packed with essential
electrolytes for hydration and it's more
cost
effective than expensive sugary sports
drinks to get 25
off go to drink hydrant dot com slash
pacman and use the code pacman
blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
non-fiction book in just 15 minutes
you can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription
by going to blinkist.com david pakman so
with just
days left in their session before the
holiday break that is upcoming
democrats and republicans in congress
are reportedly getting closer
to a second coronavirus stimulus package
a relief bill as they are often called
finally at the end of december they are
closer but nothing is yet guaranteed
and i don't actually know what's worse
that it's taken seven months to get
close to a second deal
or what would actually be in this deal
which we've found out about over the
last
24 to 48 hours because this is a deal
that will include
ungodly amounts of money for many
industries
and it might include it might include
six hundred dollar direct payments
for some americans now the information
is changing
regularly one estimate was it might be
900
for some americans 600 is the number
that aoc and others are talking about
but the last estimate is it will be a
900 billion dollar total package
with the possibility of six hundred
dollars
in direct payments to americans and in
the meantime
it would include that blanket liability
shield
for companies against coronavirus
related lawsuits that's something donald
trump has been talking about
after the first stimulus package when
discussion of the second one started
donald trump at every opportunity would
say we want the liability shield for
companies and the
understand what this is a lie a
coronavirus liability shield for
companies means that
if there is an employee or a customer
that gets the virus because of how
your business handled social distancing
and and sanitary guidelines etc
you have blanket protection from being
sued for that
and it is essentially just an open door
to companies to do whatever you can to
increase profitability in the short run
with no regard whatsoever to the danger
that you may be placing
your employees or customers or both in
as a result of ignoring guidelines which
may make you more profitable
it's that that would be in there but
they're battling for six hundred dollar
payments
for individuals the package again as of
the latest iteration that we've seen
reporting on it would not include any
assistance to state and local
governments
which is sort of where you need to start
to properly
manage the different ways in which this
is affecting different municipalities
and states so
it's just so pitiful and embarrassing
and pathetic
there's really no other way to say it
600
some people received 1200 back in may
plus those six hundred dollar a week
boosts in unemployment for people who
were laid off
it's been seven months since that with
nothing
who knows even if this is approved
and that's a question mark how quickly
the money would actually be distributed
and make it into people's bank accounts
and they're talking about maybe six
hundred dollars
democrats propose doing another 1200 and
they've been proposing that since may
that went nowhere some of the more
progressive democrats
including friend of the show who we
spoke to not that long ago congressman
roe khanna
have proposed two thousand dollars some
have proposed two thousand dollars per
month
that's all going nowhere very very
quickly and and
the reality is you know i i never want
to scoff at anything
when we know that half the country can't
meet an unexpected 400
expense you see the number 600 and you
say well we that's
we shouldn't scoff at that okay but the
reality is that 600
if you're doing fine doesn't change
really anything
and if you're if you've not been doing
fine since may
then what 600 is going to do materially
i get it you know me
maybe this makes it so you can make half
your rent payment next month and that's
better than nothing
but it's not about beggars can't be
choosers
it's that the argument over whether we
give 600 or 900
to people after seven months of nothing
given the economic situation
communicates a complete lack of
understanding as to what's actually
going on in the united states for
tens of millions of americans right now
even the first
stimulus with the twelve hundred dollars
it's fine and it was useful for people
but if you were employed at that time
and you were continuing to work to earn
a living
uh the the twelve hundred dollars was
not likely to affect
your viability financially over the
course of the entire pandemic and that's
why stopping short with that and then
going seven
months with nothing is delusional what
really was the lifesaver for a lot of
people
back in april may was the enhanced
unemployment of an extra 600
a week which by the way in large cities
particularly if you have
even just one child it's barely enough
to get by
without working and in some cities it's
not enough to get by
and look at how many businesses were
closed at that time
so this is a great example of how being
cheap is really expensive and we've
talked before there's
there was an interesting article i
recommended it must have been a year ago
maybe 10 months ago
about how being poor is really expensive
and it
it the article explained you know if
you're poor
you're likely going you're more likely
to go to the bodega in the on the corner
to get four rolls of toilet paper rather
than ordering the 60 rolls from amazon
which are
better quality and cheaper on a per roll
basis
but you've got to lay out some larger
amount of money
up front and in that sense it's much
more expensive to be poor because you're
often buying items at a higher unit cost
sometimes of lower quality and spending
more time acquiring those items because
you're making multiple trips
instead of you go on amazon and you get
the big box of toilet paper it's an
example the way it applies here
is it actually applies to a lot of
consumer products
you buy the really cheap work boots this
year and you probably have to buy
another pair next year and another pair
next year
or you get and that gets really
expensive in the long run
or you buy the really good boots with
the lifetime warranty
you do have to spend more now but your
long-term cost is lower
the way it applies to stimulus is you do
1200 bucks in may
and maybe 600 now and it sounds like
you're saving a lot of money relative to
giving people
fifteen hundred dollars a month two
thousand dollars a month sounds like
you're saving money
but when you consider that that cash
payments are demand side stimulus and
they stimulate the economy
plus higher long-term payments allow
people to stay home and be more
responsible
which slows the spread and we know that
every person who ends up in the hospital
for corona with coronavirus
places a huge financial cost on the
system you realize
the higher outlay is cheaper in the long
term by suppressing the spread
and case in point you look at european
countries that are only in their second
spike now
that entire summer period in the
northern hemisphere
where they had relatively normal summers
economically was much better
than what we've had here where we are
now on our third peak we had peak number
two
during the summer and it was disastrous
for business and the economy
as we continued to hemorrhage jobs so
that's a long way of saying
one of the richest countries in the
world which some love to say
is the greatest country in the world
whatever that means finds billions
for corporations in certain industries
and we're arguing about six hundred
dollars for people it's pathetic
canada did two grand a month for seven
months if you were working but didn't
earn very much you qualified at least
for part of that some provinces even did
additional payments
so what congresswoman aoc and some
others are saying is if you don't find
the 600
appropriate get in touch now with your
elected officials
and tell them that but really more is
needed i mean
you know if this doesn't justify mass
rallies at urban centers i really don't
know what does
don't these members of congress and
senators work for us and of course
that's true
in theory it's true on paper in reality
they're mostly serving the interests of
big corporations
how disconnected from reality do you
have to be
to think that six hundred dollars after
seven months of nothing
is going to solve a problem and
stimulate the economy it's
completely it's magical delusional
thinking
one of the things we wonder about is
does donald trump know he lost and he's
pretending to have won
for optics or to keep raising money from
his followers
or does he actually think he is the
rightful winner of the 2020 presidential
election
i actually believe that may be the wrong
question people like donald trump
narcissists with delusions of grandeur
and a complete inability to self-reflect
they hold contradictory beliefs at the
same time
or sometimes they switch erratically
every 30 seconds
between one belief and its opposite cnn
is now reporting that donald trump has
told some advisors
that he is simply going to refuse to
physically leave the white house
on joe biden's inauguration day january
20th
aides report being alarmed by donald
trump saying
i'm just not leaving because as you can
imagine secret service escorting a
president out of the white house
would be fascinating but it would not
exactly do wonders
for donald trump's legacy but then after
saying i'm not leaving
trump reportedly kind of walks it back
and starts talking about who he wants to
pardon
on the way out and looking forward to
just heading down to florida seemingly
recognizing that he did lose and he will
leave
now i'm not surprised by this the
discussion about
does trump know he lost or not this is
exactly the type of thing i would expect
where one second he's insisting i'm not
going to leave because i won
and the next second he's talking about
screw this i'm out of here
i'll go play golf give me a list of
pardons to sign off on
there's nothing at all shocking or
unusual about that for someone of
trump's personality and disposition
the other funny thing is that at this
point
i believe that most of the people
convinced that trump did
actually win and joe biden stole it
recognize that unless you get some legal
determination
to overturn the election trump can't
just
sort of stay at the white house like a
squatter that that's not going to be the
way it works
i think even the people convinced trump
did win
know that unless you get some
uh a court or or or a state to overturn
a result
you can't just sit at the white house
they they know even that's not going to
work and in all seriousness
i would be willing to pay money to see
donald trump dragged out by secret
service
but ultimately it's not going to happen
and trump may even end up vacating the
white house
this month there are rumors speculation
that he'll head to florida
uh around christmas or after even though
we go back and forth though trump's
going to do christmas at the white house
or maybe not we don't know
trump may leave the white house later
this month and not even come back
or maybe he will and he'll be convinced
by someone around him you know you
should really be there on january 20th
i don't know there would be nothing
better for ratings there would be
nothing better for shock value there
would be nothing better for comedy
than trump being physically removed from
the white house but it would be a
disaster for the country and
i don't think it's actually going to
come to that now in the meantime
prepare yourselves for a flurry of
pardons
donald trump is getting endless requests
he's regularly asking people around him
should i pardon this person
should i pardon that person what about
this one people are skipping the normal
process
normally to ask for a pardon you go
through the justice department's
pardon attorney with trump everything is
insane
everything is childish everything is is
unorganized
and so people are calling jared kushner
they're emailing trump's chief of staff
mark meadows
if they have a direct line to trump
they're just asking trump it's like a
feeding frenzy
of people asking for pardons and what's
interesting about that is
even though there is a formal process
for asking for a pardon in theory
anyone who knows this administration
knows that with trump
it's who can get in front of trump when
he's paying attention for 30 seconds
and maybe get him to sign off that's the
way it works and they're completely
right their instinct is exactly right
so we'll see how the pardons go but
donald trump will leave
and in preparation for trump leaving and
joe biden coming in
uh on january 1st we are doing a one-day
huge membership special if you've been
thinking about signing up if you are
sort of ready to make the commitment uh
to being a member
get on our mailing list at
davidpakman.com and then on january 1st
an email will go out which will tell you
here is how to take advantage
of this borderline illegal and certainly
immoral
membership special that will be themed
based on the date it will be 1121
and the membership special will be
themed
on that basis okay sign up for the
newsletter
davidpakman.com on new year's day we
will let you know how to avail yourself
of that special
and of course let me know what you
expect between now and january 20th
from donald trump i'm on twitter at
deepak
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
one of our sponsors today is nebia the
creator of the world's most
innovative shower head it uses only
about half the water that other shower
heads do
saving you money helping the environment
but it's actually a lot more powerful
than other shower heads on the market it
has twice the coverage of other shower
heads
the water sprays with a ton of pressure
i've been using it in my bathroom at
home
i love it only took a few minutes to set
up really easy and it's been a totally
different experience
than any other shower head i've used i
can get in and out of the shower way
quicker now because of how powerful it
is
it only takes a few seconds to get
completely rinsed off
so i was actually amazed that it's only
using about half as much
water nebia also offers a number of
shower accessories like shelves and
curtains which match
perfectly with the design of the shower
head the shower head starts at just
199 but the first hundred people to go
to nebia.com
pacman and use the code pacman will get
15 off site-wide
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
remember that the number one way to
support this program is to grab a
membership at jointpacman.com you will
get
instant access i do mean instant at the
speed of light
let's put it that way uh access to the
bonus show
and also access to commercial free audio
and video streams of the show
grab a membership at joinpacman.com also
please follow the discussions taking
place
respectfully on the david pakman show
subreddit at davidpakman.com
reddit that's r-e-d-d-i-t more than uh
more than 26 000 can you imagine
more than 20 these are numbers no one's
ever seen before
more than 26 000 of our viewers and
listeners
uh participating in the discussion up
one user
suggests i was checking out some of the
discussions this morning
one of our viewers says i think there's
a lot a 95 percent chance
republicans will try to impeach biden on
day one
going on to say honestly i'm not even
being facetious i think they'll start
bringing forward articles of impeachment
the minute biden is sworn in we all know
what's the first thing they're going to
try to impeach him for they will argue
biden is an illegitimate president due
to mass voter fraud
and election rigging in the 2020
presidential election
they might also cite ukraine scandals
being unfit for office or
cognitive impairment or make up a
corruption story
um i i don't expect uh
impeachment um articles to be filed
against biden
um right away but uh i would certainly
i mean listen this is one of the most
weaponized republican parties we've
we've seen as long as i've been
following politics closely
which i would say at this point is about
you know 20 years
um this is one of the most weaponized
republican parties so i wouldn't be
surprised at some point
to see an attempt at impeaching joe
biden and again
this is why uh democrats have control of
the house
and control of the senate is in question
based on the january 5th
senate runoffs in georgia if democrats
control the house and the senate it puts
these fears
essentially to bed another post from the
david pakman show subreddit
which is not as convinced that the
december 14th
elector vote is the end saying
it should be over with the electors
having voted but
trump supporters among them elected
officials are holding their delusions
close
and vowing to disrupt the certification
of ballots on january 6th
even after that the inauguration could
be targeted i keep wanting to celebrate
and see us moving on but unlike the
trumpists i see the clear reality
that we are not out of the woods and
more insane even violent actions are
still a possibility sorry to say
i actually am i'm less worried about a
disruption on january 6.
i assume that some republican members of
the house will stand and object
when certain state elector votes
electoral votes are being counted
maybe even some members of the senate
will stand and say uh mr speaker or
whoever
you know mr senate president which is
going to be mike pence at the time i
object
but i don't think that's going to go
anywhere the violence does concern me
more because
at any point there's a tinderbox
situation here if trump says the wrong
thing or the right thing depending on
your perspective
i think the the sycophants are ready to
go absolutely
crazy claiming they are defending who
the person they believe to be
that they see as the rightful winner of
the 2020 election so
that worries me more than any serious
disruption to the process
on january 6th let me know if you
disagree
and join the discussion at
davidpakman.com
slash reddit so uh
listen there are people who would feel a
sense of satisfaction
from what i'm about to play for you i
feel no satisfaction whatsoever i
i actually feel despair when i see the
video i'm about to play for you
because it's emblematic of so much of
what's wrong
with our country this is an example
of yet again another republican
who was very laissez faire about kovid
and stood behind trump literally and
figuratively
with no mask defending everything trump
was doing
praising trump until he got coronavirus
himself
and i'm talking about former new jersey
republican governor
chris christie who ended up after not
wearing a mask at the white house at a
super spreader event
chris christie ended up in a hospital
icu
with covid and now chris christie
is in a national ad defiantly
and powerfully advocating for mask
wearing
so take a look at the ad here is chris
christie specifically with a message
to those refusing to wear a mask this
message isn't for everyone
it's for all those people who refuse to
wear a mask you know
lying in isolation in icu for seven days
i thought about how wrong i was to
remove my mask at the white house
today i think about how wrong it is to
let mask wearing divide us
especially as we now know you're twice
as likely to get covet 19
if you don't wear a mask because if you
don't do the right thing
we could all end up on the wrong side of
history
please wear a mask so chris christie
says
as we now know but we've known this for
months
so okay it's true we maybe didn't know
in february and march
about masks but chris christie got
coveted a couple months ago
we knew for six months at that point
about the importance of wearing masks
and not doing indoor events everything
that chris christie participated in
which likely
got him the virus so i i get it on the
one hand good for chris christie
and i see lots of leftists retweeting
this ad on twitter
okay but this goes back to one of the
real
tragedies of the republican party and
reactionary right-wing thinking in the
united states this is not new if you've
been watching the show listening for a
while you've heard me say this before
his view changed only because he got the
virus
and he may only be willing to do this ad
because ultimately donald trump already
lost and he knows that there's
less of a political risk to doing it
this is just like the homophobic
republican
who spends 20 years fighting against gay
rights and then finds out
their kid is gay and has an awakening
okay it's great when someone comes
around to the correct position there's
no doubt about it
but why does it have to happen only when
you uh
uh recognize that it affects you
personally it only happens when
you have a kid or or what you right
we've talked about the homophobic
example
can't you simply empathize with the
parent of the gay kid
who sees you fighting against gay rights
and and have that same awakening
couldn't chris christie have understood
the importance of masks without ending
up in the icu personally
after taking his mask off at the white
house why does it take
being in an icu with coronavirus
to understand what we should be doing do
you think that there's something
physiological going on where some of us
are able to say
hey you know what i didn't have covet
that i know of
in fact maybe i did actually back back
in april but that's a different story
i'm not aware that i i certainly had it
and if i did i didn't end up in the in
the icu
but i still wear a mask and don't do
indoor gatherings and so on and so forth
because i understand that even if it
didn't happen to me
it's happening to other people why is it
that the republicans seem unable to do
it
i don't know the answer i'm genuinely
asking it when we see
a republican show a shred of humanity
and empathy
it's because they or someone in their
family had something happened to them
and until that point they don't seem to
care
chris christie's absolutely correct and
if this video that he did if this ad he
did
convinces someone to wear a mask who
hasn't been all power to chris christie
but this is pathetic that this is what
it took
for him to come to this conclusion if
he's pushing deniers to act responsibly
thank you chris fantastic but why did it
take until almost a year into the
pandemic
if we had had more prominent republicans
saying these things in march
instead of 15 cases will soon be zero
it's like a flu
we're handling it perfectly we would be
much better off right now
i prefer public servants who can
see beyond how something affects them
personally
and understand how things affect other
people
and society at large so yeah
i i know that there are leftists who are
merely praising chris christie and
that's fine and it's fine to amplify the
message
but this is a microcosm this is
emblematic
of the lack of or inability to
experience
empathy that seems to be
an epidemic in and of itself among the
american right
and uh i i i think we can leave it there
uh but i'm curious to hear from you
we'll we'll have more on this as well as
the chris christie clip
on the david pakman show instagram which
you can find at david pakman show you
can also follow me on instagram at
david.pacman
i've gotten so it's funny i will do
something so random
and hear from 500 people and i
i i don't always understand the logic i
posted like a 10 second video on my
instagram
which is david.pakman of me out in a
rainstorm
and my umbrella reversing and i'm kind
of i'm essentially battling the umbrella
and trying to get it under control like
a wild stallion that hasn't yet
uh been saddled and uh i i must have
gotten four or 500 different messages
about this silly little video so
anyway if you want to break from the
tragedy and just want pure comedy follow
me at david.pacman we'll take a quick
break
i have so much more to talk about today
glad you're with us
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
of our sponsors is hydrant which is a
delicious
fruit drink powder that you mix into
water for rehydration
and they're giving you 25 off your first
order it's made with four key
electrolytes that the body needs
powerfully supporting your hydration
hydrant tastes great
it's made with real fruit juice it's
been a great part of my daily routine
for a while now
keeping myself hydrated puts me in a
better mood
the body needs hydration for basic
energy and focus and hydrant is the
perfect way to rehydrate
especially because it's cost effective
and lower in sugar compared to all of
those popular
sports drinks that are out there you
really have to try it for yourself to
see what i mean
it tastes great they also have a variety
called hydrant immunity packed with
vitamins a
b c and d which is also very much worth
trying
hydrant has a full refund guarantee if
you're not satisfied and you'll get 25
off your first order when you go to
drink hydrant.com
pacman or just enter the code pacman at
checkout
i've put the link right underneath this
video
welcome back to the david pakman show
today we welcome to the program lee
drutman who's the author of the
book breaking the two-party doom loop
the case for multi-party democracy in
america
also co-host of the podcast politics in
question and a senior fellow
in the political reform program at new
america and by the way
he i was hoping to surprise him with
this but he was told
guest number one thousand on the david
pakman show
unique guest now some guests have
appeared many times but we're saying
not interview 1000 lead but guest 1000
which i feel like is a more precise
metric
uh yes and and it's important to have
precision in your metrics
or else or else you mismeasure and you
lead to erroneous conclusions
right um and and so i guess maybe we'll
apply that
to our first topic which is um in
assessing
the the two-party uh doom loop that we
have as you call it
do you have a sense of how to measure
whether the republican and democratic
party right now on policy
are closer or further apart than they've
been historically
well i i think they are not
super close together but i i mean
actually this is something that
scholars of democracy around the world
do try to measure
and you know compared to a lot of other
countries
uh which just have a broader spectrum of
of parties because they have multiple
parties the
democratic party and the republican
party are
not super far apart on policy uh
you know it's there's actually probably
more in common in a lot of policy areas
what
they are divided on is geography
and identity and culture and
you know there's a real sense that you
know
democrats and republicans feel like the
other party represents a very
different and and each of them extreme
version of what america ought to be
and so the real divide is
more about social polarization than i
think it is about policy polarization
over the last couple of years we've seen
on the one hand this idea that trumpism
is something different from what the
republican party has been
for the last decade or 15 years or so or
maybe in the post-reagan era we could
even say of the last 30 years
and yet at the same time we have
actually seen
republicans by and large get behind
donald trump with rare exceptions so
can what's your sense of whether the
republican party
is fractured at this time
well i mean american
parties are always fractured because
they're these
big ten parties in a sense they're
trying to represent half of the country
i mean so yeah there i think are a few
different
visions of what the republican party
ought to be within the republican party
and you know donald trump is
sort of the vessel for at least two of
those visions
uh and it organizes the republican party
not around a positive vision of what
republicans ought to stand for
but combative
force fighting the democrats trolling
the libs i mean that that's the
the uh motivating force of
the republican party right now is
preventing democrats from
being in power uh it's you know very
much
a sense of negative partisanship and
when you ask a lot of republicans what
what they like about donald trump they
like that he's a fighter
right i mean it's not that they like his
particular policies they like that he's
fighting for them
uh and i think that that is the way that
he holds a party together that i think
if they actually had to have a
disagreement
or had to have a a debate on policy
you'd actually
find much more uh diversity
in the party it's before we move on to
how we might break this two-party system
that we have
it see it seems to me as someone who's
on the left
that a fractured republican party is is
good for the left and when i look at
what's happening in georgia
if you have some republicans who are
saying we've got to vote and then others
who are saying hey the whole thing is
rigged maybe just boycott it and stay
home and trump's going after the
governor and secretary of state of
georgia that type of chaos seems like it
would be good for the left
what's your sense of that i mean it's
good i i'm not sure if it's good for
i mean maybe maybe not i mean i think
one of the challenges
uh is that what you know
unless there's like a real genuine split
in the party
in which you know the the party actually
breaks apart
now a lot of folks are you know to
decide well
you know i don't love i think i think
this has been kind of a
a through line you know there's a lot of
folks on the right say well you know
trump is kind of
boorish and i don't like his tweeting
and maybe he shouldn't have done this
but i can't vote for the democrats so i
guess i have to vote for the republicans
and
you know hope that eventually this this
does
dies out uh you know i i mean i think it
i mean i don't think so much as what's
you know i
i mean i i consider myself on the left
um but
i i think more about what's good for
the country and what's good for the
continuation of our
democracy and you know i think that
having
a fractured and chaotic party that can
only be
unified by an authoritarian
uh you know cult of personality cult
leader which i guess is
probably the best description of donald
trump is very dangerous that you need a
center right
or a right party that believes in
basic idea that you have free and fair
elections and those
elections are legitimate and you know we
we don't have that
right now and that is that is the true
danger so i mean
maybe there'll be some fracture and
there'll be a a
a faction of the party that says look
you know
whatever disagreements we have with the
left we
agree that we have to have a democracy
with free and fair elections
and that is the cornerstone of our
system
and you know we can argue about tax
policy later but the first thing we have
to agree on is
that you know you have elections that
are legitimate
so what would have to change for the u.s
to go
more in the direction of of having at
least one more party that's regularly
viable a few of the things i've talked
to my audience about
include changing how politics is
financed uh
would would probably be near the top of
the list uh
also potentially changing first past the
post
voting at least within states so that
the spoiler effect which
keeps a lot of people from going in the
direction of an alternative to democrats
and republicans would probably be near
the top of the list
do you agree with these two items what
other items would would you add
yeah i mean i i certainly support
campaign finance reform but i think the
the real reason why we have just two
parties is because we have a voting
system first past the
post plurality single winner elections
in which votes
for third parties new parties minor
parties
are effectively wasted and so all the
all the energy and focus goes into the
top two parties and it's very hard for
new parties to emerge now the us is an
outlier in this respect i mean
most of the world's democracies uh
have proportional voting systems that do
not
punish smaller parties uh most
democracies around the world are
proportional multi-party democracies and
there are certainly a range of of of
rules that
you know can structure the party
competition i think a healthy number of
parties is probably between
four and six i'm not suggesting that we
become israel and have like
you know 13 parties uh you know
and israel uses a very extreme form of
proportional representation that i
that that neither i nor most people who
study electoral systems would recommend
you know i think the the model here
should be something more like ireland
which uses multi-member
uh districts you typically three to five
member districts with
um uh uh a ranked choice voting uh
so they just call it proportional
representation i think another model
this
might work better for the senator though
it would require constitutional
amendment
is what new zealand does you know which
is they people elect
uh representatives for for their
legislative district
and then they have a second party list
vote in which they vote for a party
and the parties get effectively
compensatory seats in the legislature
based on how well they do on the party
list so that
it ensures that if you know 53 percent
of people want democrats
democrats have 53 percent of the seats
not just how how
democrats and republicans happen to
shake out in particular states or
districts
how do you build consensus to even
change that system right because i mean
even the conversation about
electoral vote versus popular vote to
pick the president one party has
benefited from the fact that we have an
electoral college
and one party has lost out on on
multiple uh uh
presidents in the white house as a
result of that so there's a large
portion of those in power who have no
incentive to change that system how do
you how do we get over that hump
uh there are some people in power who
want to
maintain the status quo but i would say
a few things
um you know one if you talk to most
people in power
uh elected democrats elected republicans
you know
a lot of them feel like things are
really broken
and they feel stuck in this system and
they feel trapped in this system
and they you know don't actually want
you know in their preferred world they
they wouldn't just be foot soldiers in
an endless
partisan trench warfare where they keep
digging deeper and deeper
holes now you know i think within the
democratic party and within the
republican party as we were discussing
you know there are different factions
there are different groups that feel
like they have a
vision uh for how politics ought to be
and that vision is uh
is is suppressed in this current binary
hyper partisan
system in which nothing actually happens
because the parties are kind of
deadlocked
so i mean i think there are enough
people in
elected office maybe not the heads of
their parties but who might say look
this system isn't working for us and you
know
maybe we can try uh a different
system in which maybe we'd get to play a
different role perhaps a better role
in actually working out uh legislative
compromise
and you know trying to trying to solve
problems instead of just
fighting each other in endless messaging
wars in which all this money
is wasted uh just to fight to
basically the same point that we've
always been i mean for all the money
that has been spent on this election
it's remarkable
how little movement there was among
voters i mean it was you know
basically the same same outcome as as
2016
and the popular vote with biden winning
a little more and biden did a little bit
better in a handful of
states and that you know yes
that very very very well said uh so
we've talked a little bit about the
republican party we've talked about
a multi-party possibilities
to talk a little bit as we get down to
the end of our time about the democratic
party
um there was a modest amount of
sort of never biden sentiment during the
primaries and even shortly after
joe biden it became clear joe biden
would be the democratic nominee but in
the end
most democratic voters did vote for joe
biden even if they
would have preferred someone more
progressive
is the democratic party likely or how
likely is it
to fracture in a in a significant way
between the sort of
bulk of the party and the progressive
wing
well yeah i mean i think that the fights
will continue i mean
i mean a fracture would be significant
and i think
democrats unified around biden because
they wanted trump out of office that it
was you know i mean if you looked at
polls it was not
a uh a resounding
you know vote of enthusiasm for joe
biden as much as it was a resounding
vote of
of get donald trump out of office and
and now you know uh you know
who knows i mean i think you know i
think i think the the
progressive left feels um you know like
it
it doesn't have a lot of room to
maneuver given the narrow majorities
that democrats have in the house
um on the other hand gives them more
leverage but
you know the threat of trump winning in
2024
or somebody trump like winning in 2024 i
mean
this is this is the problem with our
you know closely fought binary politics
is that
everybody is just trying to win the next
election
and so there's all this you know well
you know we're not going to discuss
ideas we're not going to have debates
about policy you know we just have to
make the republicans
look bad we just have to keep them out
of office and then we have the luxury
of having an actual discussion over
policy because we can't
fracture and that's just the kind of
stasis
that politics is in i mean in order i
mean politics has to be
dynamic there have to be fights and
there have to be disagreements and there
has to be uncertainty and there have to
be
uh you know opportunities to form new
and different coalitions
but we're in this kind of frozen state
in which everybody feels like they're
losing
everybody feels like you know just one
election and the entire
uh character of america will be
destroyed
and you know it creates this
incredible sense of frustration
meanwhile there are real problems that
we have to deal with
um climate i think being to me
the the most important and existential
uh
you know that we're just ignoring
yeah i i am less concerned as you're
pointing out
the the fact that there would be
disagreement within
or or between parties but even within
we're kind of talking about here
i'm less concerned by that and that's
less of a sign that
that of a problem in the democratic
party for me the concern comes
if there is a wing that is representing
a significant number of americans
that seems to never actually get
anything for
the those constituents that are that are
in line with them
that is more of a concern for me than
the fact that there are disagreements
or even factions because that actually
seems completely natural natural and
healthy the way you're pointing out
yeah it is natural and healthy and you
know if we were in a multi-party
system you know there would be a social
democratic party
and there would be a you know moderate
centrist democrat party
and then those parties could go directly
to the voters rather than having to
compete in
in different primaries and you know we
we'd know
uh what the popularity of their
different programs
were and then those would be bargaining
chips as they worked out
legislative solutions instead there's a
sense that
you know democrats have to hold together
they have to win that majority which
means they have to win those you know
slightly conservative suburban districts
which means they can't do anything too
progressive uh
and that's just the way the math works
yeah no question about it
uh we've been speaking with lee drutman
who's author of breaking the two-party
doom loop the case for multi-party
democracy in american
in america he also co-hosts the podcast
politics in question and is a senior
fellow in the political
reform program at new america ali i
really appreciate your time today
thank you david this was this was a
great conversation and you know i hope
folks
uh you know think about this as a
serious solution to our gridlocked and
broken politics
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly
what one of my favorite apps lets you do
it's called blinkist and what they do is
take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect
for exploring a book you otherwise
wouldn't have time for if there's a full
book you're thinking about buying
you can use blinkist to get a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
non-fiction book in just
15 minutes i recently read a brief
history of time of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about
eight bucks a month and you get the
entire library
but you can try it totally free and get
25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
all right this is uh this is fun and
scary at the same time
i love a good conspiracy theory many of
you know i've been fascinated by scams
and conspiracies since i was a kid
and i love seeing how do people get
convinced of jus
such wacky things that none of us should
be believing in
mlms and essential oils and all you know
all these different scam products and
all this different stuff okay
uh if you want to read a book by the way
about
large-scale scams and and uh cults
um and a lot of the a lot of scams are
also cultish like with mlms that's often
the case
check out the book the road to jonestown
about jim jones and the people's temple
and this is the origin of the term to
drink the kool-aid it came tragically
from
from the people's temple and jim jones
okay here is a conspiracy
that comes to us from newsmax which is
one of the two networks that donald
trump has been recommending as a truly
right-wing alternative to fox news
remember
trump and some of his most ardent
suck-up followers
have been attacking fox news lately as
being liberal now because they
acknowledge that joe biden won the
election that makes them liberal now
and the theory put forward by newsmax
and i'm using the word theory
in the colloquial sense not the
scientific sense
theory very loose colloquial usage we're
going to look at some clips in a moment
the theory is as follows
kamala harris senator from california
has not yet resigned her senate seat
even though kamala harris is the vice
president elect
and will be sworn in on january 20th she
is still a senator she's not resigned
and she can vote in the senate
and her senate term actually goes until
2023
if she were not to resign because she's
going to be vp
at some point between now and january
20th
kamala harris will resign and that will
clear the seat
for california governor gavin newsom to
select a replacement
the theory goes on newsmax that the
reason kamala harris hasn't resigned
is because it's an insurance policy
because
deep down kamala knows she suspects
maybe she knows that it's actually not
going to be
joe biden sworn in on january 20th
deep down this is me this is not my view
right i'm telling you the theory
deep down kamala suspects trump will be
getting a second term not biden
so she's staying in the senate so that
when she doesn't become vice president
on january 20th
she can stay in the senate until january
of 2023.
that's the theory let's check out some
clips this first one
is a news max host i don't know if it's
pronounced grant
stinkfield or stinchfield these are
names we may have to become familiar
with as media critics for the next
couple of years
here is grant stinkfield exp explaining
what's going on with kamala
here's the reason they want senator
kamala harris
to be promptly inserted as president and
may i remind you
harris is a woman who has yet to resign
from the united states senate in
preparation of becoming the next vice
president and ultimately
president if the media gets their way
why hasn't she resigned yet
because maybe like all of us she still
thinks president trump has a shot at
victory if
only all the evidence of fraud can be
proven
and exposed so that's the idea kamala
suspects she may not really end up
being the vice president so she's
holding on to that
senate seat here's another news max host
this is greg
kelly who suggested the exact same thing
just a few days prior
to grant stinkfield mentioning it take a
listen
by the way i think the blind people
aren't as confident
as they are trying to convey you know
kamala harris has not resigned her seat
i'm told
uh yet in the united states senate
barack obama when he won back in 2008
he resigned before thanksgiving i think
they're um
just keeping their options open
depending on
what happens so there's the same idea
from another newsmax host greg kelly now
this this maybe could actually be
instructive any time you're presented
with a conspiracy theory
you should know the process to go
through to
evaluate it and before you even start
evaluating the conclusions of the theory
you have to start with fact checking the
premises the first
question would be is it true that kamala
harris
has not resigned from the senate yet
that is true
okay that's step one number two is it
unusual
that she hasn't resigned yet halfway
through december
before a january swearing-in well
it is true that barack obama did resign
his seat in mid-november in 2008 when he
won the presidential election that part
is true
but what's unusual is how early barack
obama did it it's very unusual in
if you just go back to 2008 then senator
joe biden
didn't resign from the senate until five
days before
he was inaugurated as vp in 2009
a george w bush didn't resign as texas
governor
until late december in the year 2000.
bill clinton didn't resign as governor
of arkansas in 1992
until very late december al gore
didn't resign as senator until january
of 1993 even later than bill clinton
when al gore was set to become the vice
president
george h.w bush's vice president dan
quayle
didn't resign from the senate until
january
of uh the inauguration so there's
nothing unusual going on here and that's
where the conspiracy theory falls apart
it's predicated on everybody else has
resigned so early
no no no the truth is almost nobody
has already resigned in mid-december
when they are set to be inaugurated as
president or vp
in late january of the following year so
the most
likely reason why kamala harris is not
yet resigning
is that number one typically that's how
it works so she's doing what most other
people do
and number two she wants to be able to
vote in the senate because it's not
clear how quickly california governor
gavin newsom will be ready to replace
her
and you don't want to have an empty seat
in the senate uh when democrats want to
have as many votes as possible including
possibly on very important things
like a second coronavirus stimulus
package so this is another
very silly conspiracy theory and we are
likely to hear
many more of them on newsmax and on oan
and i'm sure on fox news as well
over the next two to four years and in
fact i want to go
next to talk about fox news briefly so
as i've told you before
even when you hear populist rhetoric
from the right
it often is followed up by the worst
policy ideas or blame games
sometimes fox news propagandist tucker
carlson
sounds like a populist not that
different from bernie sanders
in rhetoric except in the next breath
tucker will warn you black lives matter
might steal your house
and so you need our version of
right-wing populism to protect you from
that or
it'll be immigrants will steal he'll
sound like bernie and then say
uh immigrants are making us a dirty poor
country which he has said before
and very often let's be frank guys uh it
is a very sp
it is hanukkah very often the tropes
go to the jews the anti-semitic tropes
will bubble up
in the most unexpected or maybe expected
places if you know what's going on
and that's where tucker went with a
segment a couple of nights ago he
starts with the perfect lead-up to
blaming jews
which is to talk about people conspiring
to secretly control you
if i've ever heard a good premise for an
anti-semitic trope it's that take a
listen to this
welcome to tucker carlson tonight we
paid close attention to
a number of big elections recently but
it turns out that many of the most
important elections are the ones you
hear
nothing about the news media barely
covers them
most voters don't know they're happening
as a result of this
a small group of committed extremists
gets to control the outcome
of those elections often with disastrous
results it happens all the time
and who is one of those people secretly
conspiring to control you
and others well of course it's old rich
jewish guy george soros this is
uh this is beyond parody now but that's
where tucker
is going with this check it out that's
not democracy as we were taught it
yet increasingly it's how things work
here george soros understands that
soros has an eye for vulnerabilities he
became extraordinarily rich by finding
ways to exploit the weaknesses in
systems that he did not himself build
in the early 1990s soros became a
billionaire by shorting the british
pound crushing the bank of england in
the process
he went on to repeat those tactics and
other financial crises in countries
around the world
and then george soros turned his
attention to the united states where he
decided he would fundamentally change
our society
it's actually amazing that for all of
the dressed up
populist rhetoric and man of the people
stuff and
smart conservative tucker carlson who
doesn't play the games republicans play
he's back to blaming george soros for
our problems disguised
with the same anti-semitic tropes that
we've been seeing for 150 200 years at
this point
and he continues with this check it out
if you're wondering why
so many people are being robbed raped
and killed in american cities right now
george soros is part of the reason for
that soros has funded the campaigns of
left women's
extremists in district attorney races
all over the country
in cities like philadelphia st louis
chicago boston
traditionally a prosecutor's job is to
enforce the law
but soros wanted rigid ideologues who
would refuse to do that
and instead let murderers and rapists go
free while allowing our society itself
to degrade and collapse people are being
robbed
raped and killed because of george soros
how did you not know that
now you know how i've been saying that
in all likelihood
the return of a normal person to the
white house in joe biden
means everybody goes back to the normal
playbook republicans go back to
pretending to care about the deficit
and these faux populists on the right go
back to blaming the jews
or brown immigrants for everything it's
the same old playbook
this is an anti-semitic trope that goes
back centuries the rich
jew using subterfuge to control others
and manipulate society almost like a
puppet master
behind the curtain controlling the
marionettes for personal gain
it's just anti-semitism guys it's it's
well disguised
sometimes anti-semitism but that's all
it is
when the right talks about george soros
it's code for the jews
george soros is just a rich 90 year old
who survived the nazi occupation of
hungary
before moving to the united kingdom
after world war ii
but he's become code for he's become
emblematic
of the jews and most of them know they
can't
say the jews so they say george soros
uh it's a meme and it's a dog whistle
and a very obvious one at that
to many of us but it still gets by a lot
of the fox news audience now i know that
some of you will say
david there is no evidence that tucker
is personally anti-semitic
um if if that's where your head is
at this point then i probably can't
rescue you
but as we've seen with donald trump as
the perfect example
it's less about the personal beliefs
about
jewish people or hispanic people or
black people or whoever
but it's about playing into the tropes
and fomenting these ideas repetitively
that that's actually what this is about
arguing about what's deep inside tucker
or trump's minds
uh uh that that's that's significantly
less important but right on cue
everybody going back to the standard
playbook and the roles we would expect
them to have
during a more normal uh administration
we have a voicemail number and that
number is a 2192 david p now
i am i'm glad to be corrected on this
program i love it
um on the bonus show the other day pat
and i discussed
the idea of vaccination stickers a
sticker that says you've been vaccinated
and we talked about the possible
positive impact of that including that
it would create
uh sort of like a public movement to
encourage others to be vaccinated but i
heard from a bunch of people
with a very different view and clearly
this is the privilege i have of living
in
a blue area folks who live in red areas
have written in saying those stickers
could get you attacked
and the egg man who lives in a rural red
upstate new york wrote in rather called
in
and said exactly that take a listen to
what he had to say
hi dave and pat i'd like to respectfully
disagree with your opinion
on wearing the i got vaccinated stickers
yeah i live in an area that is so
red that if i went around with and i got
vaccinated
right i might get assaulted i'm not even
kidding with you
i actually gave blood this morning and
the nurse who took my blood
told me i would never get that vaccine
it's horrible it's not tested
she literally mentioned right wing
talking points but i hear trump say all
the time conspiracy stuff
i'd be afraid to wear i got vaccinated
sticker
the same way as i'm afraid to put i
voted for joe biden sticker on my car
in the area that i live thank you shalom
yes all right shalom as well to it to
eggman uh peace and love
he he's right and uh i i think maybe
pat and i were a little bit um uh
anxious on the trigger of saying this
would be a great idea
because there are people in in many
parts of the country
who uh may not so easily be able to just
walk around with their unvaccinated
sticker
it could actually cause them problems so
let's continue to think about it and
think about the right way
to sort of publicly encourage folks to
get vaccinated but i
i think the eggman brings up a very good
point we've got a great bonus show for
you today the swedish king
carl the 16th gustav says
that the coronavirus approach in sweden
has not gone so well
we will talk about the possible return
of the iran nuclear deal
we will talk about an important supreme
court decision that may be coming
soon get instant access to the bonus
show by becoming a member
at joinpacman.com
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
nebia is a revolutionary showerhead that
saves you money by using
45 less water but with a stream of water
that's way more powerful
than what you get with other shower
heads to get 15 percent off
go to nebia.com pacman and use the code
pacman
hydrant is the delicious fruit drink
powder packed with essential
electrolytes for hydration and it's more
cost effective than expensive sugary
sports drinks
to get 25 percent off go to drink
hydrant.com
pacman and use the code pacman blinkist
is the app that helps you become a more
well-rounded person
by letting you read or listen to an
entire non-fiction book in just 15
minutes
you can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription
by going to blinkist.com david pakman